hey everybody it's Mike from
immortalflows and welcome to today's
video you know today is Monday January
16th 2023 it's Martin Luther King day
here in the US so the cash markets are
closed the Futures are open but you know
it's sort of that uh you know next trade
date scenario where you know even though
we opened up Sunday night as per normal
um you know we trade until 12 o'clock
and then it goes into a halted period
until five o'clock and then it reopens
and it's all considered the same trade
date for trade date Tuesday
um so basically you know any trades you
did Sunday night Monday morning it will
be for trade day Tuesday
because it's a non-clearing day and
you know people have always asked me you
know how do you trade you know these
days where it's like a holiday period or
a holiday itself
um you know where volumes are lights
well it's simple you you just don't
trade it right you just wait for the
time when volumes are there now you know
there's nothing wrong with watching the
markets it's just that
um you know on days like today you know
a a non-clearing trading day where the
markets are open but you know the
underlying
you know cash markets are are closed
like in the S PS
um you're not going to get very much
movement right you're going to get
movement you know people are still
trading it for whatever reason and you
know it's just moving very slow so you
gotta keep in mind that you know if
you're using your normal profit targets
they might not get hit at all in that
session okay so you know you can see
here basically from you know 11 to 11 25
on my chart or basically trading between
40 11 to 40 you know call it 4013 you
know a two-point range over 20 minutes
it's just not you know going anywhere
and it's frustrating because sometimes
you're so used to how the market moves
during a normal trading day that
you know on a day like today you're
sitting there like it's like watching
paint dry honestly
um at least there was some movement in
the S PS I mean we did you know go from
about 20 down to 10 you know here was
that 19 and a quarter we got down to
around the tennis area
um but again you know you don't have to
trade every single day right there's
nobody putting a gun to your head and
saying oh you got a trade but if you
have to or you want to or you want to
get some screen time you know my
suggestion is to watch the market
outside of the US right watch things
like you know the the nikai during the
Asian hours or buns
um
as well you know but again you got to be
watching it during that time zone
ideally because
after you know their cash market closes
in the Buns there's just nothing
happening you know in the US there is
some movement you can see here but
obviously the the good movement is going
to happen you know during the European
time so let's just sort of go back and
you can see the the nice movements that
you're getting here and what was
interesting
was you know this was a great example of
Supply coming into the market now
generally you're going to see Supply
coming into the market when prices are
rallying all right because that's a
great time for people with Supply to
sell it very easily right if you have
Supply in the Market's rallying it's
easy to move size but what do you do
when you have Supply to move
and the Market's dropping well if the
market is dropping you don't necessarily
want to be hitting all the bids right
because the more you hit the bids
the more Traders see that you know
volume is coming in on the bid side you
know and pushing the market down so what
you have to do when a market is dropping
I say what you have to do what I mean is
what the big Traders will do I mean us
the small Traders you know our five
contracts isn't going to really
influence the market one way or the
other but if you're a big Trader
okay and you know you've got Supply to
move once it sort of hits that Tipping
Point you got to be careful because you
don't want to give it away so to speak
you know give away your hand on what
you're trying to do in the market of get
rid of your supply by just hitting all
the bids so you can see in here right
this move down right basically from 138
you know we'll call it 138 15 all the
way down to
um you know this area here 137 65 so
you know more or less about a 50-point
drop and pretty quick you know in about
less than 30 minutes okay so you can see
you know the sellers coming in they're
being aggressive they're hitting the
bids here 147 you know 36 54 the 110.
you got those selling of balances it
continues in the next bar you're seeing
some more selling imbalances in here now
you're seeing some buying imbalances
okay I'll get to that in a second but
sort of once you start coming down into
the low right and you've been if you're
a big seller and you're trying to
sell
you're going to get to the point where
it's like okay you know we're above the
low I could I could be aggressive but
when you start coming into the low
you got to be a little bit you got to
start finessing the order
right you can't just go in and start
hitting every single bit in there so
what you're going to be doing is you're
going to be working offers right offers
on the way down and you can sort of
start to see it coming in in here right
I mean there's 700 that traded at this
138 11 on the bid but then you know
there's a nice offer that came in again
for 400 here okay so you're seeing the
volume is starting to pick up sellers
are coming in right they're already
coming in because you can see that
aggressive selling
as the market is dropping now you're
starting to see the offers come in here
right the 427 and then when you hit that
sort of that that Tipping Point which is
the low of the day the 138 even you know
138 even is it's it's a it's a figure
right it's it's a nice round number
it's the low of the day
and as opposed to just sort of coming in
and just you still got
remember people big Traders got Supply
right they got to get rid of it
coming into the low rather than just go
hit all the bids right they have to
finesse it so they're going to be
working offers right through 345 the 222
right the the 311 the 307
okay even here 400 you see this Market
making new lows
for one bar two bars three bars four
bars five six seven I mean we'll call it
six I mean three is is
not much
but you got six solid bars with six
solid positive deltas
this sort of goes against what your
brain is is has learned about Oracle
because normally you expect Market three
going down on negative Delta but why is
it going down on this positive Delta
well the reason it's going down on the
positive Delta is because you have
big sellers you know that are working
passive orders that are absorbing
whatever buying there is off this low
and look at this as you're coming down
into the low
it's pretty consistent right that 200
and 400 300 300 300 right so it's
they're there right at look at this this
is coming at 91.92
94 95 97.
right and even here at at O2 so
basically between 97 and 91 you're
seeing decent size offers come in at
pretty much every price level right 97
95 94 92 91. all right for at least you
know well this is 300 347 300 400 and
this is just 200 but you're seeing some
solid offers coming in okay and you know
that should be a clue to you that you
know what Supply is coming in but what
was interesting is when you start
putting it together you're seeing yeah I
had that aggressive selling as we're
coming into the low okay but then as we
come into the low that aggressive
selling I mean they're still obviously
aggressive selling because we're taking
out the lows but what you're seeing
trailing it
is
the big offers coming in the passive
sellers people that still have stuff to
sell but they don't want to just come in
and just hit all the bids to help add
fuel to this move down
because then once we sort of break this
you know even you break this 80s you
know this low here you know we still got
moved down to into the 60s another 20
points all right even get down into the
50s down in here
but that was you know that was very
interesting to see that happening
in the Buns this morning now this is a
one minute chart okay so you know that
was a nice movement
um
currencies okay no you know so there's
you can look at uh you know currencies
because you know the cash markets are
always you know basically it's 24 hours
a day
um 24 6. now British pound okay so
British pound is is you know it's become
one of my favorite currencies to trade
whoops
6B should be
um sort of like uh sometimes it trades
like a like an altcoin so this is a one
minute chart and you can see during the
US session it's pretty quiet but you
know what you'd want to be looking at is
is during the European session right the
British the English hour so to speak GMT
time
um
and it's sort of going back in here
now this is on a one minute chart okay
whether using a one minute chart a five
minute chart it doesn't matter right
because you're still going to see the
information it's just going to be
plotted differently so this is a one
minute chart but what was interesting
you know again similar thing we're
coming down into the lows and what do
you see right you see some you know
aggressive selling but then you see you
know the big volumes coming in sort of
trailing it down and it's coming 449
Lots you know a seller there for close
to 450 at this 211 period
okay so I know that you know we're
coming into the low I see a big seller
coming in
on the offer side not a big seller
hitting the bid side but a big offer
coming in is telling me you know yeah
there's probably some Supply in this
market if you were to go to a five
minute chart times around two in the
morning
um let's pull up a five minute chart
here a little bit
because you're sort of a slightly
different uh view of what was happening
in the market
but again you know
coming down into new lows and you're
seeing you know the big offer coming in
we had just traded there
then a big offer is coming in and you'll
notice what happens in this where that
offer is you know the one 2230
right you're just
draw the line here right
came off came right back within a tick
of that and sold off some more
again from this once it's sort of thick
got these lows then you know dropped
from 14 down into the 80s
pretty quick
you know this was less than an hour a
nice move there but again you know on
slow days you know what I would key in
on is things like the volume you know
how is it appearing you know if you're
making new highs or new lows is it
supportive to the market or is it acting
as resistance you know where's the
supply coming into the market or is
demand coming into the market that's
what you want to be asking yourself when
you're watching the market on a slow day
and again you know personally I think
slow days like today you know it's going
to be slow I mean you don't have to sit
here and stare at the screen for two
hours
saying oh this is long just you know you
can anticipate it's going to be a slow
day so just take the day off but again
you know if you're going to be trading
on a day like today like a holiday
clearing holiday
um look for signs in the order flow in
terms of big volume and where is it
transacting is it transacting on the bid
side or the offer side and what it means
to the market
so all right everybody enjoy the rest of
your day off and I'll catch you guys on
the next video bye-bye